prévert que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui dure
pas très longtemps en raison d'un
gameplay extrêmement nul et d'une
chanteuse très élevé dans cette vidéo tu
as tout le monde puisse à bientôt ou
plutôt à tout de suite
je demande s'il devait en être
aujourd'hui sur
dreamcast collection un ajout qui
regroupe quatre jeux connus de la
dreamcast donc des jeux qui date un peu
aujourd'hui on fait une vidéo sur ses
cabas speaking parce qu'aujourd'hui je
suis chaud pour aller à la pêche dans
les rares cas la stimulation visuelle
par certains effets stroboscopiques au
motif que mais ne peut déclencher une
crise et j'ai pu étant donné leurs aveux
chargement en cours j'adore l'icône du
chargement un bon gros poisson en train
de mourir ça ça te met tout de suite en
confiance les normes voulait vue au
jeu comprend rien et prend les bordels
et comment faire
mais [ __ ] mais il va se laisser faire
ce gros poisson mais je comprends jamais
allé mais bien
ta il faisait 3 kg 8 merde zéro g c'est
pas bon repas servis g c'est déjà ça oh
la la c'est très dur à faire une image
comme ça à l'époque mais trahi game over
sur un lac c'est moi qui vous le dis il
y avait du niveau comme
qui vais-je prendre
lui j'avais faim elle a d'accord c'est
elle qu'on va s'appeler 7 8 5 ce end
785 sièges aux lignes 785 alors faut
trouver un endroit tard une école comme
ils se déplacent sur son bateau score
exceptionnel quoi un bon on n'a jamais
vu ça il a des sponsors en plus over
spinmaster
sponsors un peu un peu cool alors
pourquoi ils pêchent tout près de la
côte je sais pas non plus peut-être que
empêche c'est comme ça je sais pas mais
y'a pas un [ __ ] de tutos de sa mère
vient là poissons de merde
bien pu tester un petit loup il faisait
5 kg merde dans ce jeu vous serez
capable de voir un mouton sous l'eau là
comme ça d'un coup il arrive par la
gauche vous avez vu ça moi je propose
qu'en fait on fasse un tour en bateau
allait mais
le gameplay le plus passionnant du monde
quoi c'est incroyable allez un petit
poisson mais juste un petit point
comme ça
ou alors un gros comme
tu l'as vu eurêka
en fait faut tourner le pad comme si
c'était une ligne
voilà
c'était très compliqué à comprendre
finalement
[Musique]
change alors ça me fait transpirer ça
mais je transpire sur un jeu de poissons
bordel à la haute dans la grotte au
comment je le sens bien dans la grotte
vous l'avez vu vous l'avez vu manger à
manger n'importe quand vous avez faim je
sais oui s allez allez allez
oui vient de battre un magazine tchô
pleut il est à toi est à toi
cette boisson de merde j'ai plus
l'impression
rappelait mon ancien métier vous êtes
une famille d'enfants et de poissons de
mer dont vous les parents j'ai alors
allez crever de faim j'en ai marre de
jeu pourri todorov pis à bientôt
[Musique]